una vez más en el foro económico mundial
en davos Ucrania estuvo en el centro de
las conversaciones el presidente
ucranianonski se dirigió a la asamblea
en videoconferencia lamentó el accidente
de helicóptero en el que falleció su
ministro del interior y pidió un minuto
de silencio
14 familias ucranianas han perdido hoy a
sus seres queridos Y muchas otras
familias también los pierden a diario a
causa de la guerra
y les pediré que honren la memoria de
cada persona que Ucrania ha perdido con
un minuto de silencio por favor Tom
aprovechó para pedir más armas más
rápido por parte de sus aliados
occidentales reunidos precisamente el
secretario general de la otan James
toltenberg anunció que la alianza
reforzará el apoyo a kievón
Si queremos una solución pacífica y
negociada a la guerra en Ucrania debemos
dar apoyo militar a Ucrania Esta es la
única manera allí las armas son el
camino hacia la paz y Aunque suene a
paradoja es la única forma de llegar a
un acuerdo negociado y de convencer al
presidente Putin de que no van a ganar
en el campo de batalla y que tiene que
sentarse a negociar
quien presiona para recibir tanques más
potentes como los leopards de Alemania
sin embargo el cáncer olafones no
mencionó la entrega de estos tanques que
aumentarían la capacidad defensiva de
Ucrania entre tanto la agencia de
Estados Unidos para el desarrollo
internacional anunció que prevé aportar
125 millones de dólares adicionales en
ayuda energética de emergencia para
Ucrania